JOHN ESSIGMANN: One of the
physiological scenarios
that we teach, and
is probably very
common in biochemistry courses,
has to do with diabetes.
I'm diabetic, and my great
grandfather was diabetic.
His daughter, my
grandmother was diabetic.
Five of her six sons were
diabetic, one of whom
was my father.
So you see a very
genetic disease here.
OK?
That's, in my case, type 2
diabetic, so adult onset.
So my cells are
insulin-resistant.
So if I eat a meal that has
carbohydrate or fat in it,
my pancreas is
probably responding.
My beta cells in my
pancreas are probably OK,
but the insulin
just isn't able--
but producing insulin--
but the insulin
just isn't able to
signal my cells to be
able to take up the glucose.
As a consequence, I'm
somewhat in a technical state
of starvation.
My glycogen reserves are
therefore smaller than yours,
and I can tell this in times.
For example, when I
first became diabetic,
I loved mountain climbing
and hiking and so on,
and I noticed that
I would go out.
And I'd be totally exhausted
for the first 10 minutes or so,
and that's because I have
very small glycogen reserves.
What I had to do is
this metabolic switch
over to booting up oxidative
metabolism of fats.
That all had to be
turned on, and it's hard.
It's a hard transition,
but once it got going,
as long as I stay
aerobic, in other words,
I don't go so fast that I go
anaerobic, I can climb forever.
Because if I stay aerobic, I've
got plenty of fat reserves.
In fact, it's probably a good
thing that I'm burning them.
So I'm just a little
bit different.
I like to teach
this stuff in 5.07,
in part because well there's
probably not that many kids
in the class, of 100, 130, or
so, students would be diabetic,
but it's about 6% to 8% of the
population in the United States
right now.
So everybody knows
someone who is diabetic,
or maybe your parents are,
and what are the risk factors?
So we teach that.